[Music]
what is the most bizarre sport that you
guys have come across my maken is that
Olympics with their spiced curly curly
that was called yeah that the bruise in
East Coast sport is Canadian Canadian I
own that [ __ ] over here scan it over
there have you seen that up it's like
girl basketball but they played in
that's the weird
I don't cuz I don't see guys playing
this game I'm legit like they don't
dribble the ball they just pass it and
it's like basketball and they wear
skirts for the uniforms wait guys wear
skirt no no it's like this is basketball
I forgot the name of it yeah it's like a
basketball are they jumping on
trampolines
it's like field hockey but for
basketball like field basketball yeah
it's like basketball but they don't
dribble but they pass anywhere shirts
and in their uniforms are skirt yeah
then like juliek the like the the
powderpuff type [ __ ] show this on
pornhub it's a specific search I didn't
know that this was a popular thing
because I thought like rugby or whatever
even though we don't play it here it's
something that will be like oh yeah I've
seen this before
I was linked a professional like play of
this a team playing doing all this stuff
and it's I was like it was like women's
basketball but not like female NBA would
you call wmba it was a math name yes
yeah laughs when you say WNBA why do you
love what I said female duck it duck NBA
that's why yeah you set them up right
now I gotta find the leak man it was
crazy yeah but while you do that I'll
finally get you guys will trip the [ __ ]
out all right we're gonna trip the [ __ ]
out on this first all right so this is a
traditional sport in in China a
traditional traditional yeah okay cool
here we go come foo and tell me what
they're saying it's all Chinese
that's that's for sure enough the animal
doesn't have to just [ __ ] so it's a
sport that in China is the traditional
sports it's like passed from generation
to generation
I act like the main that Ming Dynasty or
whatever oh that's old yeah very very
old man when I said traditional like
it's [ __ ] traditional that [ __ ] came
before broccoli beef dude you know in
American high school it's like oh shoot
hey you're a tall guy you everything
about playing basketball like how do you
recruit for these you gotta see three
home girls that are already just kind of
walking right behind each other same
size you three BFFs
in order for them to actually be in this
team yeah can you imagine the Scout he's
just at the park he's like I never seen
anybody walk like hey you two could you
walk a little bit closer just go where
you think it's going but just trust me
on this like China the military is so
crazy and how they're like they're
marching and stuff together maybe
they're just like those one guy that was
like true you know and he like found
that it was like what are you doing is
like oh it's a sport yeah as we trust me
I'll bet you a piece of wood should we
tie shoots it yeah yeah this sounds like
a lot more than what I was gonna put
onto the feet yeah and then that's how I
became a sport how do you win I think
it's a race so you're you're competing
with three other people where I guess
team two threes and then so it's not
like it's there's no style yeah I think
it's pretty style points I'm like I
don't know I don't know about the
distance maybe a really dope Nike shoes
that it will put
have you sick thank you Lisa gate
because it might be that's like a
billion dollar market of billions of
people there because if anyone have
blocks of wood and then you saw like AI
team come up with those Nike shoes like
a Nike swoosh on the way one long swoosh
yeah damn it's like just what about a
barbell Brigade learn more about not too
much just if you don't wanna commit to
that just yet no you ain't go ever be a
lifting thing where there's multiple
people lifting one thing the weather is
already there's what's not as popular
it's like strongman kind of stuff isn't
like doable CrossFit because it makes
kind of sense right like if you think
about like Lumberjacks and [ __ ] like
that they had to kind of get together
sauce for it's like they would do like
team ones mmm for powerlifting it's like
andum [ __ ] but it's for funsies it's not
like yeah you can do tandem powerlifting
like two people when people just like
want to [ __ ] around [ __ ] no wait
anytime in a sport one person has to
hold the other person's waist it's funny
figure skating and of jet ski weeks ago
kinda back dude holding on holding on
for dear life is do that with skiing
happy sitting I'll be like a crash would
be like one guy goes this way one guy's
ankles are flying no but I'll do this
there was more accidents and sports I
would watch it
what kind of like NASCAR seeing people
just explode no right out the window
yeah this sport they were like as
accidents all the time he's like now I
would not like exchange would you watch
next names
yeah it's okay explain yourself crashing
all over the place the crash so you
don't see that what's going on inside
the car unless they cut to an angle
what's they usually don't like what
people's limbs get limp and [ __ ] because
people are flying everywhere because
like that yeah so that but you want to
see him get hurt yeah motorcycle racing
a motorcycle racing that's it's crazy
because one eight lighting yeah that's
all one recently where the guy who likes
living he was a crack days and he was
just walking and then another guy like
oh no cuz you don't want to hit that
guy's bike and that's that more cycle
goals are just [ __ ] knock that guy to
there
he was fine though as your favorite
sport now huh your favorite yeah he was
clapping yeah I like the cycling we're
like one person in the front falls and
the whole group falls right for using a
bicycle but yeah so this sport how do
you know if it has a name
board shoe racing board shoes
International League now these these
times are they like translated just for
English are they oh yeah they always
sound like very literal too many words
boards to racing how do you translate
basketball board shoe got a here it got
here they're not even yeah what were
they saying you're saying football
everyone's talking about that in here
and then Americans took the all the way
or she racing they are super super sure
sounds like it's just [ __ ] Barney do
cuz it's like it reminds me of the
pictures from prom oh it's funny cuz the
lady on the front is doing this when
they work I don't I don't I can like
make out what they're saying cuz they
have like a accent if a hillbilly accent
not a hillbilly but like kind of yeah
yeah but they couldn't have hard time no
you know you never saw that ever before
this never I've never seen this before
either and I thought I was how are you
ship it around for woodling thousands of
years hundreds of years dynasty I only
thought about putting people separate
and so raising mind-blowing abouts been
around forever isn't running ready it's
called netball I [ __ ] around let me
show you guys you think I'm [ __ ]
around right rotate they've played in
Australia that looks just like
basketball yeah but they don't dribble
though yeah
see okay hey look at this [ __ ] how come
my phone is a lot you look good yeah
wait wait there's no there's no backward
close to the camera so it's just a net
so it's like volleyball in my life and a
girls look like they're wearing tank
tops dresses the amount of things I've
seen in my life hot sport do you see it
I'd rather play this dude [ __ ] going
into a lake and fishing with my arm got
a catfish I didn't know those are the
only two options
netball it's called netball there's a
catfish you crazy you know like if you
had a super hot though really it's
difficult not to keep watching netball
they're so hot I'm saving that for later
maybe that's why they're so popular it's
re because of the sport it feels like
it's like basketball for white people it
takes away one level like a skill it's
like volleyball and basketball put
together volleyball should be so much
fun the hot girls part no it's cuz the
way that they stood there like setting
it up and shooting it like volleyball
you have to get sports bar that are only
these weird sports I played that would
kill like that'd be so fun all the
tedious boards big events but I don't
want I'm there do I talk to friends and
stuff and then we joke around
I don't want every just facing one way I
go for the wings so that just don't have
it on well but these sports though
that's like something to talk about like
what the hell's going on now be fun like
that's more like that's for besides for
this board we go back to what he doesn't
want to do they want or don't want and
then immediately go back yeah the right
examples is exactly there's like no
I never contradict myself hanno your
talk about the dean first three examples
you throw like hey this is what I like
what about this like mmm don't like that
oh my god accidents in sports or oh
that's my math what about these three
artists no because I keep a [ __ ] to
anything and then the first board shoe
racing just a little history on it
yeah it's created for to train soldiers
for against Japanese military tactic so
I guess Japanese Jack Sparrow's out
there huh they had to get rid of
Japanese your dream come true but
basically some general it's a female
German mrs. Walia she created this
method to help synchronize the marching
of the soldiers desktop they had female
generals back then according to the
legend that's why trying to lost hey
take it back you bastard this correlates
to winning against somebody
Botha marching the marching maybe if
they had like two mannequins on a
platform so one soldier can go like seem
like there's three soldiers and then
they could see seem like there's more
Obama than the Japanese pirates would be
like folk of that [ __ ] and then they go
back it sounded really specific wasn't
just like you know for military purpose
it was like against Japanese pirates and
I'm like what combat is specifically
right before the board to go against
pirates and it wasn't we see those like
guys that have like everything taped
alarm and they're like dancing it's like
that's what they're shooting arrows and
they're hitting the wrong guys and then
makes that army look bigger
yeah that's true damn Japanese pirates
ma'am I'm learning a lot of jazz right
now and I'm trying to piece them all
together and you can't not hear you
can't it's a wrong please
[Music]